intimacy love and marriage are three
different if interrelated subjects so
the way it's phrased right over here the
the writers saying that you know these
are these are three different subjects
but they're giving a little bone to the
idea but you know yeah I admit they are
interrelated so even though they're
definitely are interrelated they are
different subjects so that's how it
reads there and it's not badly written
intimacy love and marriage are three
different if interrelated subjects it
feels a little bit a little bit
convoluted I might want to say that
three different subjects although they
they are definitely interrelated as well
or something like like that so let's
just look at the other options so this
is it as it's written not horrible but
let's see if we can think of a better
way to phrase that intimacy love and
marriage are three interrelated subjects
being however different that's just
convoluted and in it and the real point
of it is that they're trying to say that
they're different subjects although
there yet you know I'm willing to admit
that they are you know they're not
they're not completely unrelated so but
this one right over here this one is
emphasizing that they're interrelated
subjects and giving a little bit bone to
them being different so this is a
different meaning and it's very cuddled
being however different so it's
unnecessarily the about all those commas
in there and it's kind of hard to read
and really long so let's look at choice
C intimacy love and marriage are three
different subjects whereas they are
interrelated well once again okay I mean
they're making the point that there are
three different subjects whereas they
are interrelated yeah yeah I don't know
that's its whereas seems you know kind
of kind of formal kind of legalese
whereas they are interrelated that also
because of that that convoluted phrasing
and using of whereas seems a little bit
unnecessary that's definitely not as
good as the first choice intimacy love
and marriage are three different if
interrelated subjects intimacy love and
marriage are three different subjects
when interrelated oh no that's that's
just definitely wrong they're not only
different when they are interrelated
that's not
that that's a completely incorrect
meeting intimacy love and marriage are
three subjects that are different
although being interrelated although
being interrelated so it starts off okay
intimacy love and marriage are three
subjects that are different if there if
this was kind of a period and then say
and/or but or even if it was a common
but they are also related then something
like that might have been okay but
although being related so yeah that this
is once again this is just kind of a
phrase a weird phrase to start on the
end of its all I'll cross that one out
so really the best one is it as it's
written there are three different if
interrelated subjects it's kind of the
cleanest it's the shortest it's getting
to the point where they're different
subjects although you're giving a little
bone to the idea throwing a little bone
to the idea that yeah they aren't
related but there are three different
subjects so definitely go with wood
choice a